beginning with kimy the squatting roll
squatting roll is essentially the same
thing you're going to do as a regular
roll the only thing is you prepare for
it a little differently by letting
yourself get really low anytime you're
taking out forward roll you want to get
as low as you possibly can to the ground
but we sometimes forget that when we're
getting exciting about taking a roll so
the squatting roll is an opportunity to
let yourself get low in the squatting
roll the very first thing I'm going to
do is squat
low to the ground like this as I squat
down I'm going to make an arch out of my
arm as my arm comes down I want to
imagine the pressure staying even from
my pinky all the way through my shoulder
across my back and out my hip one of the
important things I'll also learn in the
squatting roll is I need to project
myself forward a lot of times people
think when they're rolling that they're
going straight down but you're not
you're sending yourself forward by
sending yourself forward you're allowing
more of the force of falling to the
ground to be dissipated in the roll so
instead of taking it all at once
straight down that force is dissipated
out so as I get low to the ground I push
from my back leg this will send me out
forward so as I roll I push
forward squatting roll is a great next
step in the forward roll from there once
you've got that Master the forward roll
really shouldn't be very difficult I'm
Christopher hind thanks for
watching